nous recrutons sur notre boutique de
holt rixe à coignières une personne qui
serait en charge d'accueillir les
clients de les encaisser et de remettre
aussi à temps perdu des produits dans
les rayons la personne doit être assez
autonome et toujours souriante avoir
vraiment le sens de l'accueil du client
pouvoir l'orienter vers les différentes
zones du magasin pas forcément de pré
requis sur l'information une première
expérience dans le commerce sera un plus
le poste est à pourvoir tout de suite
sur un sur un cdi en 39 heures la
boutique est ouverte du lundi au samedi
donc je serai sur cinq jours de travail
nous serions sur une rémunération du
smic + heures supplémentaires et avec un
variable sur le chiffre de la boutique
pour postuler vous pouvez écrire à
coignières arbas autres x.com ou venir
directement en boutique nous déposer
votre cv votre candidature